Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier, and welcome to
'Please Don't Touch Anything'
"HEY MAN!" I mean, I already said hi, but I'm talking about the story in the game here!
"MAN!"
"I need to take a bathroom break.
Stay here for a moment."
"Wait! What is this panel for?!"
And why is there a big red button in the middle of it?
And why do I have such an urge to press it?
"Just stay here. I'll be right back."
"And DON'T TOUCH ANYTHING."
You know, I always love it when people say the name of the game in the---
in the dialogue that they're talking --
HA-BOINK!
Oh damn it, I missed the button right off the bat-
What is that?
Hello?
Oh, it only goes on? HABOINK?
Oh, I love a countdown.
That's always a good thing!
Oh God, oh God! I already blew up the world!
YEAH!!!
Or I grew a mushroom apparently.
I heart Mushrooms! I do indeed!
Okay...
So, I did a thing...
Great!
I wonder what would happen if I actually waited for the guy to come back.
It would probably be like Far- uh-
Far Cry 4?
Was that the game?
I-In Far Cry 4, in the beginning of the game,
The guy-- I've never played it myself--  but if the guy,
tells you that he's gonna come right back
...
I wonder if you wait here long enough, if he's gonna come back
I have no idea.
Probably!
Why is there the number '666' on that desk?
Also!
I didn't- Oh, God! There are instructions?!
Hang on!
'One, grab your screwdriver'
'Two, GREE your hammer'
'Four, work-' FOUR?!
'Three-' Oh, God, I don't know what that is!
Why is there an equation on there?!
Ahh! I don't know what that means!
What does that say?
Correct?!
C-Correct??
Oh! Is it upside-down?
These are clues, obviously.
For things that I need to do in the game
I think...
Why is there a pentagram on there?
How long has it been? I have no idea...
Am I supposed to wait around for this?
I don't know how long I'm 'onna be waiting for it!
Oh...
*laughing* Nevermind, then! I guess I'm done!
"Great! Thanks, man! You've really helped me!"
"What took you so long? Something could happen!"
"Really?"
"Like what, the apocalypse?"
"You've got to have an education to run this machine."
"Let's go."
Are you calling me stupid?
I'll blow up the damn city! (Probably Detroit)
God dammit...
Do I have to restart?
Dammit!
Alright.
Huh-boink.
Alright...
So there's gotta be--
Ahhhh!
I know what I'm doing!
What happens if I press it a whole bunch?
Yeeaahhh, I'm pr-- Ooo hey.
Oh cool!
Oh perfect!
Ooo!
I dunno what that is!
Ahhhhh!
Oh, oh hang on.
Ok so a combination of four.
There's only so many possibilities
I could probably brute-force my way through that.
I don't know how to do that.
And what is this?
Ok, one two three two one two...
Ok.
So...
On line...
...three, technically line four, of the instructions,
there's numbers...
So there's one...
One, one, two, one...
Button? No...
Ok...
One..
How?
Oh...
One, one, one, two, two, one...
No?
Why'd it go away?
Three, one, two, two, one, one?
Dammit.
Ok, maybe, uhh...
Uuuhhhmmm...
Okay.
So...
If I'm looking at the correct thing upside down,
then it'd be pointing at bottom right,
bottom left,
bottom left, bottom right?
Dammit. Okay. Wow I'm not doin' good here.
I'm trying guys!
I'm tryin'!
What happens if I press the button some more?
Is something gonna happen?
Oh!
Yes!!
Yeah!!
Ohh...
Oooo...
What is that?
Hello?
Hi...
BWUUAAHAHA!!!
I found a secrehehet!
Oh...
What the hell?
WHOA! What is tha-
Wait, don't do that!
Wha- didit- ju- Oh God damn it!
Why'd you crash the game?!
Still running? Yeah, it's still running. Okay, we are good.
Alright, we are back in the game!
God damn...
It is really lucky!
I just changed my recording setup for this video!
And I can handle it crashing now!
Okay... That's good. Okay, we're fine.
Alright so I need to press this a whole bunch.
What happens if I keep pressing it?
Oh...
What did I get?
What is that?!
What IS that?!
Does that say "dunce?"
No, that says dum...dum-
That says "dummy!"
God dammit! I'm not a dummy!
Aw man...
Okay, hang on.
Ok, "Grab your screwdriver, grab your hammer."
"Work."
And then whatever the hell THAT says.
Okay, so there's something to...
...this color panel...
*mumbling* Is there something on the...
Th- obviously the clues are on that sheet!
Do I...
Can I hammer that...?
Ooo!
Hi!
What the hell is that?!
I dunno what that is!
What do I do?
"B, D1, D7, 4"
And it looks like there's s-something missing there.
I think that's like a slot or something?
What is that?
Is it a clock? I think it's a clock.
Wait does it-
...
Wait a minute.
Hang on.
Yeah!
Yeah it's a clock!
Can I hammer it?
Can I break it?
No?
dammit
fuck
AWWW!!
COME ON!
I was in the middle of the thing!
It's still ticking away.
I'M NOT STUPID!
I'm a thmarty!
I'm a buh-
I'm not a dummeh!
...gotta be something else...
...here...
ʰᵉʳᵉ
Oh.
[Alarm alternating tones]
[Mark is spooped at alarm's alternating tones]
...the fuck did I-
Oh!
[alarm makes rhythm from tones]
What the fuck is that?
Oh okay. Oh I get it.
WAAAAah!
*Horrified" AHHH!
Wh-h-hat the hell!?
Okay?!
Ohh God!
Aah, I just hit the baby with a hammer!
Ahh Jesus!
Oh, why am I doing this?!
Oh jeez!
Oh, it's got a shield!
Oh okay, that makes sense.
Okay, hang on.
Wait-
Oh God!
Why does it have growth?
Why does it have-
Puss-bubbling tumors all over the place?
Ew...
Oh my God!
Oh shit!
OH! It's dripping blood towards the restart button!
NOOO!
OHHHH GOD DAMMIT!!
OH I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOIN'!!
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STOP ME!
YOU'RE NOT GONNA RESTART ON ME!!
OH GOD I wasn't paying' attention!
FUUUCK!!!
AHHHHH!!!
Don't do it, don't do it man, don't do it!
BAHH!
Ohh!
OOH! That's an upset baby!
*laughing* Ohhh my God!
What th- ohh...
I don't know what that is!
I don't WANNA know what that is!
WWAAEHHH
UWEHHHH
Heh heh
*chuckling* Oh my g-
Oh-ho, okay!
Ohh God!
I got some weird heart, artery combination art on the wall there
Great I'm collecting posters!
I just beat a blood baby to death with a hammer!
I can't believe I said those words!
What the fuhaahack!
Awa- "Awaiting input?!"
What do you mean "awaiting input?!"
Button?!
Oh
Button?
Why are there buttons?
Why are there so many buttons?!
I didn't do anything!
I did-
I didn't unlock a secret!
Oh God damn it, okay...
...trying to remember where the buttons were...
Oh jeez...
Ohh God!
I think-
Oh God my brain is...
warped...
Ahh!
AHYEAHH! Okay!
"Thank you for cooperating."
"You got the jo-!"
Whhhhhaaaat...Stuuh--?
My name is Stanley!
I think-
Judging by this over on the right side.
Yay! I know my name now, I think...? Okay...
Good God, is there anything else I can hammer?
Okay..
So there's gotta be something here with this--this color.
Like, this color is the next puzzle that I--I need to do...
So there's gotta be like...
*sigh*
I tried hammering this, right? Can I hammer any of the paintings?
No...
Aww man
This is much more intriguing than I thought it'd be!
I had NO idea that it would have so many different options to it,
but okay!
Heh heh, an' I'm touching everything!
I'm still wondering why there's a pentagram right there.
Ooohhh!
That's roman numerals!
Ohhhhh!
Then that would be "1-3-2-2-3-1." Okay!
"1-3-" it's not the colors, but it's something!
Yes!!
"Don't do it!"
I don't know what you want me to do.
I wis- I wish I knew!
Okay.
So, there's an arrangement of four buttons.
What if I do the thing?
It was-
Bottom right,
left, left,
right?
OOOOOOOHHHHH!!
YEAHHH!!
Okay!
Alright!
WOOOOOOO!!!
Okay!
Oh my god!
I was right!-
Okay
I was right.
So,
what does this mean?
"D4...?"
I dunno what "D4" means.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
I gotta get up to "247?" Jesus...
*speeds up*
Okay,  closing in on it.
"276"
Wait a minute..
Wait!
What?
Wai- why did it--
*click*
No?!
Oh!
There we go!
Yes!
Okay!
I got it!
Yeeahh!
YEAAAAHHHHH!!!
What?
"Green"?
Oookay..
I'm still causing an apocalypse..
But I caused something new to happen.
YEAAHHHH!!
I did a thing!
Ookay.
Good for me, man,
good for me!
Okay, but.. I think..?
I think there's a-
There's a "666" here.
I think if you click that thing 666
times,
something else happens.
But I don't have the patience for that.
Okay.
So lemme go back to the- "132231"
Okay
So..
Is that a switch?
Yeah!
Ohhh!
Hello!
Numbers!
Okay, numbers.
"1,1,1,2,1"
Oh, only 4 numbers...
Jesus.
Umm...
There's numbers in the equation...?
"8..."
"3,6,7"
YESSSS!!
Okay!
Got it!
Alright!
Okay!
This's good!
Uhhhh..
*whispering* What is this...?
Oh jeez.
Okay! So this is next to the "666."
Does that mean--?
Ah, no the "666" was the other thing.
Uhhhhh...
There's little dots!
There's little dots by..."work,"
which is line 4...
which is line 3...
soo...
dot dot
dot
Okay, so...
It's line four, so the 4th row down...
Do this.
No?
4th row across?
No? Dammit.
Okay..
I thought I had something there.
Alright.
Umm...
But it's "1-..."
"1-2-4-3..."
And there's "1-2-3-" so-
"1...2...4...3?"
AUAHH!
Yes!
Okay!
Alright!
It counted it up!
Woah.
Oh!
So, we had some sort of singularity happen there,
and it sucked it all into another dimension.
Great!
I'm so sorry, whoever lives in that city.
I am wrecking shop here, but I'm doin' good.
*laughing* I'm doin' good guys!
I'm doin' good!
Okay...
A'right, let me try...
The other way...
There we go. Okay.
Ah! What is that?
Woah.
Oh!
Uhh- Whaaaaat?!
HELLLOOO!
What are you?!
Ooo! Oh, that don't look good!
Someone had a bit of a--
"Accident" on that button over there.
Alright.
Oh. Wow! What the hell?
*laughing* Kaboom, kaboom...
Oh maaan!
Oh God.
Is that Pluto?
Pluto's not a planet anymore...
It's so sa-- oh my God.
Oh...
How am I gonna remember these numbers?!
Oh God! I can't remember that!
How am I gonna be able to--? Oh--! Oh jeez!
Aw, jeez.
Is that a person?
Aw, jeez Scoob!
Aw, jeez!
Oh my gaaash!
Oh ma gash
Oh ma gash- Oh someone died here.
Oh, wow. Okay.
What is th- Oh, Pac-Man!
Oh, okay!
Oh, cool!
Ah, jeez.
Nothin' up there...?
No secrety secrets?
Oo
Hello
Dot?
*mumbling* D-O-T...
Woah.
Morse...?
OOHH!
Wait.
AAH! Okay.
Morse...
...dot.
Ostap Bender?
What is that on the sides of it?
Ok, this means something here.
This means something. Okay.
So, if it wants me to do Morse code...
"Don't do it..."
"Dot..."
I can translate zero and one to Morse code.
Oh man. It's been so long since I learned Morse code.
Ummm.
'D' is...dash, dot, dot;
'O' is...
'O' is triple dash,
and 'T' is just dash -- I believe.
So...
If zero is...
...dot...
...one is dash...
...it'd be...
...dash...
Oh.
Dot, dot.
That seems like the appropiate--
Dash, dash, dash...
...dash?
OHH MY GOD!
YEAAH!!!
HOLY CRAP!!
I haven't thought about morse code in YEARS!
OH MY GOD!!
OOOOH GOD!
AAAAOOOOH! My God!
I'm just amazed at myself, there.
Everyone give me a moment to high-five myself a million times!
YEAH!!
I'm gonna leave that totally uncut,
so you guys know that I didn't look it up
or any bullshit like that.
YEEEAAHH!
Oh, pat me a million times on the
back!
Ow, that hurt. Okay.
And I kind of flooded
everybody, I guess, but that's cool.
Oh man.
Oh, I got that!
Or maybe I just got lucky with something else,
but I got that!
Holy shit, look at me.
Oh, look at me.
Okay, I- enough...enough self-congratulations.
Enough masturbatory session here. Okay.
So!
Ah, okay.
Whew, all right.
Which way did I go before...?
Um...
That way? Okay.
So, I think I got everything there...
Is there anything up here...?
I'm out of breath! That was too much. Okay. So...
What if these...
...these dots here, are also Morse code, and...
it's like: 0-0-1-0-0-0-0-1.
Ah!
Heh-hey!
Oh my God!
Hello, buddy!
Alright.
Sorry about that, everybody else.
That robot needed a place to live.
I think he's starting to lay eggs, so you
better tuck in for a while; he's gonna be stampedin'.
Oh, this's cool. It's cool!
I get to use my brain!
Oh, I got Bender!
"Kill all humans," that's nice.
Okay...
So...
Oof...
Alright, anyway...
3-2-2...3-1...
Okay, which way did I go on the other time?
Alright. It's a num-pad.
So, I did...
I still haven't figured out the colors -- or have I...?
No, I haven't figured out the colors.
"The colors" was like a basic one.
That was one of the earlier ones. There's gotta be something simple to that.
*mumbling* Grab your screwdriver, GREE your hammer...
GREE your hammer. GREE your hammer. GREE...?
Why's it GREE your hammer?
Does that mean something?
Could it be...
Why's it GREE?
That's clearly not an A.
There's something there...
It could be...
GREE...
Green?
All green?
No...
*grumbles*
*muttering* Okay...
8...3...6...7...
Oh! Oh, I just noticed -- on the bottom one -- i-it's eight squared plus three squared...
That could be 8-2-8-2. Hang on.
8...2...8...2...
...dammit. Aw, man.
Maybe I already...? Ah, no. Okay.
Sooo...
Like, I-I would think that the dot pattern would be this,
because it's the exact same
number, but I can't seem to get it,
unless I was doing it wrong like the reverse...
Hang on, let me re- let me restart.
I'm going to try the, uh...the number pattern thing.
Dammit, God damn it!
Fuck that. Okay, hang on.
I don't know...don't know what I'm doing there.
Whoa, what the fuck is that?!
What?!
Oh my God, are you serious?
W-When did they decide to put a minigame in a within a game?
Oh God, it's game-ception! Hueh hueh.
Why am I doing this?
Why am I blowing up the town?
Such a horrible thing to do.
I'm about to hit the ground. Uh-oh.
*splode*
OOOHH!
I had one block left?! One block?!
And you game over me, you son of a bitch?!
Fuck you!
Fuck you, man!
All right fine, I'll get ya.
I'll getcha next time.
I wasn't ready for ya this time.
Okay, so left...
Alright. So, let me try 8-2-3-2.
YES!
Okay. Wow...!
Uuuh...
Is there a date around here?
Why...? Oh!
Oh! I went into the future;
the moon is all asploded!
Oh! So if I- Oh, I thought I had to enter
someth- what is- wha- I- hang on!
Aw, I saw something in the bottom right!
Fuck me...!
God dammit. Alright, it'll pop up again...maybe.
Dammit. *muttering*...to the righ-
God dammit not to the right!
Fuck that shit.
Ah, there! See?
Hello. Hi...
OOOH! Whaaaaat?!
It's "Papers, Please" all of a sudden;
how 'bout a big "no" to you?
Fuck off! Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, geez... Was this made by the same people?!
Oh, I didn't know that!
Uh-oh. Arstozka got all...
...got all grayed, there.
Okay, sorry! I'm sorry.
Hang on, let me do that again. Oh man, I did
not know that this was made by the same peop-
I should have known by the...
by the styling of it.
Wha-? *gasp* I got a badge!
Oo, I got an Arstotzka badge! Thank you.
I know a lot of people have wanted me to play
that...um...but a-and the odd thing was,
I was gonna do a let's play of it, like,
three years ago when it first came out,
Uh, but then for some reason I got
distracted or something, Or I...
I didn't know if it would do well o-or
something like that, or...
I dunno. I go- I got- I got sidetracked.
Okay, let's go BACK in time.
Wow, that is farther than I wanted to go.
Ah. Yes. Okay.
Cool!
Alright, I got it.
I don't know how many of these I'm gonna
be able to get. I can only assume...
...it's got the number 666 by it, and I notice
now, that kinda looks like a star...
...and there's a red pentagram up top...
So!
If I draw that, it gives me five, right?
Fuck!
I guess I could...hang on...
Wider?
YES!
Oh God. What the fuck are you?
Ew. Hiii! Can I blow you up pleas- oh, I can't even
press the button anymore.
You're leaking blood everywhere...! I'm
sorry for summoning you demon.
Could you please go away now?
Oh boy.
I think I remember those symbols
around the Illuminati triangle thing, but...okay.
Bye, now! I'm gonna go away! Have fun! Oh geez, okay.
Alright, so...alright, I gotta figure out the color thing.
Argh, this one's staring at me in the face, I know it.
*sigh* I DON'T wanna look up the answers yet.
I don't. I've been doing so good!
Fuck... I-Hi, Chica... I know.. I've been doing real good,
it's fine...
Ugh! Maybe... Maybe since the other one was
upside down on the arrows, maybe this one
is top left right right left? Dammit.
*sighs* fuck
What if it's not GREE? What if it's GRBB?
And that could mean "Green, red, blue, blue."
YES!!! Okay! Oh, we're counting up again!
Whoa... Everything went opposite.
Why did that do that?
I mean, it's cool--this poor town...
Why is this console so powerful?
Oh man, but I got it! I got it!
Okay. Alright... Okay, what else even is there? The- there's a lot of unlit lights here.
I'm not a hundred percent sure...
What else I could possibly do...
what happens if...
Okay, so I did--I did the thing for the color panel...
What if I do this up, right right, there?
Oh, that's one- oh that's one too!
Oh!
SORRY!!! OH GEEZ!! Uhhh, well, I'm sorry 'bout that!
I think I got everything on the right side! OOOOHHH! I GOT EVERYTHING ON THE RIGHT SIDE!!
Okay, I'm doing great! How many are left? 1-2-3-4-5-6-7-8-9
Ooh! Nine left! That's a lot! I don't know if I can do that.
Wow, that is a lot... Aw man, where else do I go from here?
Oh, what else is there?
God dammit! Okay, DON'T MISS DON'T MISS, DON'T MISS!!! BOINK! BOINK! YEAAHHHHH!!! *sings* I did it! I just needed to clear the city!
"YOU DROP ALL BOMB" Yay! "PRESS RESTART TO CONTINUE"
I got it! Did I get a- OH! I got a sticker down at the bottom! Thank you very much!
Okay, I gotta figure out how to get back to that thing though...
I don't remember what I did is the probl- Oh! Did I do th- I did the button combination.
Okay, so, "bottom right, left, left, right."
Alright, this was the thing... So, I'm pretty sure, if I click this 666 times... Something's gonna happen.
BANG! Okay, so now, either I press this button or, yeah, I press the red button.
HABOINK! WHOOOA!!! WHAT IS THAT?!? WHY IS ONE BROKEN?!?
*sings* I do not know! What do I do with that?!? I'm not sure!
What do I do?
Ooooh...
What is this? What is this!
Ohh! Okay, so I gotta- Wait! I know this! There were the symbols!
The symbols when the thing was on the screen! the symbols when the Illuminati was up!
It was... The "two waves."
It was... Oh, what was it? It was... The waiting sign!
Uhhh, fuck! The moon? No. The key? The key was definitely apart of it!
Now, it's just one of the other ones. So I gotta figure it out...
OHHHH YES!!!
Yay! Happy! Wow, the demon symbol turned weird! But the Illuminati one had different symbols!
Ahh, okay! The "allumimanati" one had different symbol, but I don't know I have the patience
to click 666 times, AGAIN, to get back to that. But, BUT,  that's a possibility.
Okay, so that's another one though. That's another one.
Okay! So I'm down to... Seven left!
I'm gonna try to get one more on my own, and then I'm gonna consult a guide.
Alright, I-I-I'm officially stumped. I'm gonna go consult a guide. I'll be right back.
I'm sorry to do this! I was really trying, but I was struggling.
I know there's some other stuff that I'm missing here, but... Man, I don't know...
Alright, I'll be right back though...
Whoa! Okay, I would not have been able to get this one... So, this one is in relation to the line... The third line, with those numbers in it.
The 1-1-1-2-1
1-1-1-2-2-1 and  3-1-2-2-1-1.
How in the fuuuck?
Okay! 1-2-1-1.
Okay! Ah... 1-2-1-1...
Why was that 1-2-1-1? Ah, that's what it was talking about!
Oh! The music!
You need to reproduce the music! That's genius!
I never would have gotten that! Holy shit!
Right, right, middle, left! Left, left, middle, right!
Okay, I got it! Hang on, let me clear this out...
OH MY GOD! That is AMAZING! ... And, holy shit, I destroyed everything again. But wow!
Wow- ity, wow-ity, wow! I never would have gotton that in a million, MILLION, years!!
Alright, next one, next one, next one. We're supposedly s'posed to tap this?
OH! I thought that! Oh! "Pisano Leonardo?" Who the hell is Pisano Leonardo?
Is that on my screen or is that- That's just on my screen...
It was something dirty on my screen, don't ask about it! Don't worry 'bout it!
It's not a problem!
Okay, so, Pisano Leonardo... Who in the hell is Pisano Leonardo?!? Oh!
This Pisano Leaonardo is also known as Fibonacci!
To solve this riddle, enter the first nine digits of the Fibonacci in the number keypad.
Okay? The Fibonacci sequence is the ever increasing- You know, the Fibonacci spiral. But it's ever increasing in a certain ratio
So it's, like, 0 1, and then you combine the previous two numbers. So, 0 1, it would still be 1.
And then the previous two would be 1 and 1, so 2 the next sequence.
And then 2 and 1 would be 3, 3 and 2 5, 5 and 3 8, 8 and 5... 13? Something like that...
So I need to be able to put that in, but where do I put that in?
OH! oh... Ah, we need the screwdriver. That's what was doing it!
So the screwdriver...
OHHH! Whoa! Okay!
Ah, now how do I get-
How do I do that?
Ah! There we go!
1-1-2-3-5-8-1-3!
I would never, NEVER- WHOA!!
Hi! Welcome to the party, Cthulhu! Didn't know that you would be joining us!
What a wonderful time to have you! Thank you for being here!
Alright, wow, I NEVER would have gotten that!
Holy shit! Yeah, I'm glad I consulted it or I'd be banging my head up against the glass FOREVER.
Okay. Oh, I couldn't do that. Can I do that?!? I may be able to do that.
It wants me to change... my time? On my computer... So I gotta adjust my time...
In 30 seconds, okay, okay!
AH! Look at that! Look at that! The clocks are dangling! OH, the clocks are dangling!
Okay, so, it's gonna... It's gonna be midnight and when it hits midnight
supposedly that's when the thing happens.
Yeah, it's still going. I thought it froze for a second there... Okay!
And then something happens... And then...
Yeah! What happened? Woooo...!
I don't know what that is, but it's cool!
Thank you!
So I need...
I-I think I need to go through here again.
Oh what do I do? How do I do that?
Ooohh, it's the number of dots.
The number of dots is what you put in.
So, the first one's 1...3...2...3...1-1.
There we go. Okay, yeah! WOOOH, YEAH! Wow, they
are gone. They are just gone.
Okay, but there was another way to
interpret that. If I went off to the...
Gray ones...
Instead I went off of the dark colored
ones but, I if i go off the gray ones, is that gonna do something else?
Three, one, three, three, three...
Which is nothing... Because the last
one is 4, okay, so you can't do it anyway.
So restarting! Okay! Alright, just wanted to be sure! I'm not smart!
This ending consist of connections with other ending. It will blow you away.
To start, reveal the screwdriver open up the
panel
Okay. Okay, uhm turn the left side numeric keypad
so 8367 Ooohh.
Ahhh.
Okay. Ahh, So these are coordinates on the
board, these are coordinates for this so
B scratched off the- ther- that's why there
was another button over here that was
that said D4 so I'm assuming that that's
the D and then there's probably just
another number that goes around but
apparently it's B4
D1, D4, D7 and F4 is the last one and I
don't know where F4 came from
So, but first B4, which is B is the
top, four is the numbers down right?
Is that it? Let's try that okay B4 D1- D1
4 and 7 then F4, no?
Okay the other way then, so B4
D1, 4 and 7 and F4, no? What?
But that was it, wasn't it? Was that not it?
I'm going to do that one later cuz... Not a
hundred percent sure what I'm doing.
Okay, so... Okay.
Press the red button...
Aha! Wait.
Ahh, okay.
Ooh, interesting.
Ah, ok...
Ahaa!
Wooh.
Ok, somewhere over here.
There we go!
Down.
Across.
*Markimoo noises*
There it is!
Woah! Yeah! I don't know how to do that.
I don't know what that is, every time you
turn the light, the lights ar-
Ohh. I know this, it's one of these puzzles.
These are, these are really easy.
I say as I promptly fail it
Nope, Got it!
Okay. 3 2 1.
KABLAYUUM.
Uh-oh.
AHHHHH!
Uh-oh!
Well that ain't good.
I found another way to kill everybody,
good for me. Yay! I did it though.
I got a world splitting. All right, so we
gotta get back to the lever for this one.
3, 2, 2, 3, 1, pull the lever to the right...
Okay, gotta use the UV light on the panel. Okay, this is where the numbers and I was
like "I wasn't sure what these are". There's a number of locations, now restart the game.
In the ten numerical pad, enter 20001.
Because... Alright, so now I need to enter 2001... Oh boy.
Oh... Oh, okay... Ah, I know what this! Okay, this is making sense now! Because... remember that
thing that pointed at Pluto and I even
called out "Was that Pluto"?
It wants you to say "Pluuu...
...uuuuuuuuto".
Boink! Oh, hello! What are you, what do you go to?!
I don't know what you do! What does it do?!
Uh, "press the red button for to get a lock, key lock to open up..."
Oh, to open up the right side panel, okay. Oh, and press that red button four times!
Booo! What the hell, do it!
What am I doing?! I got no idea.
Well, that's a bad thing. It's gonna come right back down on it, isn't it?
Hello! What the fuck is that?! Why is there a baby in space?!
Why is there a space baby? Is that a reference to 2001: A Space Odyssey? That might be!
Okay.
Alrighty then. Oh, I think, I think I know what the problem was. The game didn't
recognize or didn't want to give me the benefit of the doubt of knowing, but I do
know... that's a D4. Now, because that's out there, so I think I needed that before...
Ah, okay. So now, hopefully... hopefully it'll let me do it, so...
D1, 4, and 7... B this.
There we go, now it's going to let me do it! Okay, so now I enter the other code,
which, for clarity's sake, the number
comes from this right here: 4-0-2-0.
How would anyone have known that?! My goodness. 4-0-2-0. And that cracks that and
then you... Wait. Hang on...
So somehow in the 15th ending, you get this code which is yellow, red, blue, blue.
Yellow, red, blue, blue. And that opens that. How the frickafrack would you have
known any of that? Ah, alright, here we go!
Oh! Oh, okay!
The city struck back! Alright! That's all of them! Except the last one, which is
actually, I believe, not actually one, but
is actually a thing! I'm not a hundred percent
sure, I'm pretty sure, but I'm... Boink, okay.
No, not this. "Hey man!"
"Man!" "I need to take a bathroom break, stay here for a moment!"
"Wait! What is this panel for?"
"Ah, don't bother, it's just a coffee machine."
"And why is it so strange?"
"I don't know, it just appeared here one day."
"Sometimes it shows ads on the screen. You can order some coffee while I'm gone.
There's a red button."
"Ok, but don't take too long." WHAAAAAT? Boink. Oh!
Yeaahh! That was awesome! That was so cool! OHHHH I LOVE THAT.
I didn't even know it was by the
same developers of the maker of "Papers Please"
but god damn. So that- like- I can't gush
enough about how cool this was as an
experience. I mean, it would have taken me
so unbelievably long to actually
meticulously go through everything and
try to explore all the actual endings.
there were some leaps of logic and I was
doing some pretty good jobs making these
leaps of logic, but man.
As it got farther along it was just
impossible to go through. So, I'm sorry I
had to consult a guide, but this was worth
seeing all the endings so thank you
everybody so much for watching! If you
want to see other cool games like this,
I will put a link in the description to my
awesome games playlist-- there's hundreds
of cool games like this
not exactly like this not anywhere near
cool is this but some that are cool or
cooler. Maybe. You'll have to find out for yourself.
But thank you everybody again for watching.
And as always...
I will see YOU....
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!
*Video 1* *Music*
*Laughter*
*More music*
Oh, okay.
*Video 2* Candyman coming for me?
*Background music*
Oh?
Oh!
*SCARY JUMPSCARE NOISE*